this is my third grade art teacher Miss
magazine oh I'm so sorry I failed you
hi I'm autumn and I'm about to draw a
self-portrait sober I'm mark and I'm
also about to dry self-portrait sober
and I'm going to be drawing a
self-portrait while I'm drunk I am also
going to be drawing a self-portrait
while I'm in Europe I would probably
have to say that I think I am gonna be
better at portraying myself I agree
she's yeah you're gonna be better I'm
I'm in like a stone like the
stick-figure stage of artistry I think
that I personally am gonna be better at
this one I'm drunk because I'm gonna be
thinking about it less I'm gonna be more
liberal with my color usage I feel like
a solid 7 like this room like I could do
more but I'm also like pretty there I
only had a breadstick today so probably
an 8 okay okay I guess we're gonna get
started on this thing I really need a
color that's gonna suit me well look
this is a perfect color for me right
yeah I faked it this is blue already I'm
gonna draw my aura this time that's a
big part of me babe hey it's red I don't
know everyone told me that my Orioles
red first of all your head is definitely
not shaped like that no no no moving on
you're not gonna be accurate it's a
conceptual piece when I say look at this
shading giving yourself a beard take
some notes oh it's actually really nice
yeah how did you this third grade art
class she's killing me right now
this doesn't look like me really but
this most beautiful you're drawing
something but it's not you can't believe
you thought I was gonna beat that this -
you mean you know how to do all this all
this he says yeah see I just I just like
to look at art I don't know anything
about making it this is who I really am
you don't haven't seen it inside of me
ready see I see mine is more of like a
mm-hmm
you look like a insane Barbie doll
okay I'm not done yet I know watch this
get into it put your back into it
come on backs into it I really don't
know what else to do here I think it's
flawless oh my god
why is your hair like this because it's
long actually
yeah that's true this looks like a mouth
that's gonna murder you isn't it
yeah it's kind of mouth oh I didn't
actually no I didn't mean to do over the
mouth yeah very terrified I'm gonna make
this more interesting I'm gonna put a
nice thought bubble what's on my mind
you might ask money oh that's a really
big thought bubble for not a lot going
on hold on
money champagne boy I'm literally
drawing the exact same thing I did last
time
no you look so much better in this one
you think so yeah it's honestly so much
closer especially these weird ears this
is so exact like see your ear goes like
this inside and then it goes like that
you use the word weird though would you
like to expand on that
no I hate that you're actually good at
this I really don't like that
when Ian really is the aura because I
need everyone to know that I'm power and
strength ooh I just got a little on the
table red aura pencil red aura and then
smudge yeah smudge you want some red
good
I'm not red I'm not a red fine oh my god
I have to face to be your hips yeah
smudge oh and guys it nothing is perfect
this isn't else I'm gonna draw on this a
little bit because it's what I deserve I
look crazy and awesome you definitely
look crazy I'm almost done guys I'm just
trying to like you know add those need
to add some dimension alright finish
yours cuz I don't I really need some
more I can use some how I'm gonna do
teeth I don't know if you wanna have
anything
to make a normal life life woman look at
you let me get a good look
oh can you help me out for a second yes
please I can okay I want to brought and
draw some eyebrows on you first of all
because I don't do we need that look at
me mm-hmm look at how much more looks
like you know but looks so much more
like you hold on yeah let me see look at
me mm-hmm now move your hands okay yeah
okay I think this is good I also like
the wide hips that you drew yeah I mean
I got it
I'm cake that cake that I think I was
much better than I thought I haven't
busted out my drawing skills in a long
time but I feel really good about what's
going on here I'm gonna stick to my day
job but I am still happy with what I
produced I think it's a good reflection
of my character and my personality which
you can tell is really lively and fun I
think I did a way better way better
drunk because this is what I look like
inside and this is what I look like
outside yeah this is pretty much the
same as the last one I did just
different colors I think your new ones
more detailed you think so
it looks way better you look way more
accurate okay you're throwing me off a
little bit cuz you're saying this was
born detailed Minh is hurting my
feelings because I don't want to look
like this but you're you're honestly
mark you're honestly gorgeous all the
time thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]